he's a communist nazi that is a
communist that he's a communist that
he's just going to steal people's hard
work and give it to other people
just kind of tired of people just saying
that he doesn't stand a chance that
there's no way he's going to make a lot
of people say they really like him but
he's not going to win I've heard
probably a million times there's not
electable and if those million people
would just go ahead and both the way
they felt I think we'd get what we want
there's very little ever have so the gun
issue is only type of wedge issues
Hilary can try to drive home but she's
wrong on the issue that he's a socialist
as if it's a negative but I think they
just are not quite as educated as they
could be on what it really means for him
to be democratic socialist just people
like complaining about like the fact
that you support like marijuana plaguing
today if that's your major complaints
and sleep how old he is because he's not
actually dowell you married everyone
else doesn't matter the edge I think
smart enough to do everything right and
chips the United States and nights and
I'm looking forward to